5 holes in the die case bot It's an eel messed up stand, but
I'm going back to Japan in the Senryo Shimbun, but the eel never hurts.
wings to do do Disher
Hiropy Fukushima Fes the voodoo
rste A piece to luxury
[Music]
Hoop
[Applause]
Thank you for your time today.
Can you please?
Yes, the wheel method is
fine. I won. But I
was sent from that Japanese person at my house, and the owner of the anti
eel went to the airport every week to pick it up.
It's amazing that Japanese people can
think of eels. I think eels are still a little new in the United States, but I
don't think you can really tell the difference between eels and
eels.  The
eels are cooked only with eels, but the eels are served
by making Adu hr and n 4 Western foods in the morning
.
There is a season for natural eels, so the season for eels is September,
January, February, and winter. That season is fat and delicious
.
It's been delicious for over a year, so
it's delicious no matter when you eat it.
to do Thinking like that, what's the eel? Well, it's about the eel, and
it's
fixed to the eel.
Next, this is the picture movement
Edozaki eel.  In the case of, it will open from that back,
so it seems to be the same thing now, so I will bring it at once at that time
[Music]
Today
Uuu
goo n
usp Doe
4 c 6 a so  the voodoo It
's really hot, isn't it? That's the only decision.
The role of that house is to solo and raise it to keep it at that temperature
.
I'm afraid I
'll use it to get rid of it, so I'll definitely use it to get rid of it. After all, this fat falls down and this smoke comes out.
It feels like
[Music]
and Fuse Aging Transportation Aqua Week King When you leave the egg sauce, it's a champ with aluminum that is strong against professionals.
What kind of material is used for this?
8 Soy sauce Airin Sake
Sato Tsushi  The atmosphere of the carat changes,
and the scent has really improved. I've really followed the two countries
and patched it.
It's done
Ah ah ah
[Music]
Thank you for showing me various things. Thank you. Yes,
it smells so delicious, so would you like to go to work?
[Music]
[Applause]
Booby enoden  dish bar el regreso Ares
Fare jano work for
xanax Force 2 Steam
Brude
Ale
First Party Game Future xr 2 do
[Music]
f 4 ever in Fifi andaman w do
imenuma sc Seat n House gentium Aioi Ranger
Naa Seed #Akako Should Pile gurin Anagu
Inagi Sowara Cousin n Star Award Omakase Menu Food Medium Bath
pou dou dou  Asylum
4 morni display t 4
[music]
ni
me
[music]
Hmm barbar
Well then, thank you for your time today.
Ishimasu That's sushi, but I want to ask that Seki-san a little question,
so I heard that the restaurant is open
until
22:30 in that one scene, but that's because it's done until 3 o'clock here.  It's a terrible phrase
[Music]
Boo Boo s Then there's no aura, work ah ah ah ah, it's 8:30.
I'm surprised at about 11 o'clock after it's over. I'm going to spend it already.
Is that so interesting
? I was strong because I liked good boys.
Oh yeah
[music]
me is
ah ah
nao
Buba
Pudu [Music] Good Good Sayako is also a tennis made with the age of the tree.
It's wonderful. It's
delicious.
I didn't feel like I was back home.
That Asuka-san used to eat sushi when he was in Japan. He loves sushi,
so maybe he's not looking forward to it.
It feels like it's
up to you, isn't it something delicious that you bought today?
Look at a good book and make it like this Useless use a lady
Where I lived Yes Tsukiji, Yurakucho, and so on  It's about 8 to the top. It's delicious because it's
called Tsukiji. I'm
familiar with fish before installation,
then fresh or delicious. Then I'll buy it if it's close.
[Music]
First of all, it has a big impact.  Hey, let's get some money, let's go through.
This is King Salmon, a musician of salmon. I didn't carry the money out of the waiting
room
.  The reason is that the Japanese sushi
magazine is from Osaka, but somebody is brave enough to laugh at the troops, so when
you watch your TV, the entertainer who likes Eva
sushi is hi.  The school I attended is
a person who looks like a price when everyone likes to come and go
I thought it was a lap breath that we and the game are doing. Still, if you turn on the TV like a scene, you're going to be a professional right away
.
There was a player in there, and
I saw that match and used it as a weapon.
It will also be grilled Yes Nanako
I will refund the white of the hole I
made earlier
Is the cooking method of that Anako that I made earlier similar to that eel?
It would be nice if Suka Sueto could play the role of that Kabayaki, of
course, and I'd like to give it to
you.
Yeah, it's
really delicious. Die case 5 holes
.  It's definitely a glass with eels
. I think eels eat it, but that's okay.
That professional athlete's diet is
n't about daily cooking management, but how is that food management?  No,
it's really a waste of appetite until it's delicious,
but it's a wasteful booburn, but at
last there are 44
games a week, so
[Music]
Boober here
Yes, it's really hard.
I know that fat is important so I don't use too much water.
Ah ah ah ah
I'm also stressed. I can perform well if I don't eat delicious food on my left foot. It's
quite stressful.
Thank you so much, I'll definitely come again a puppy I can't help but eel yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[applause]
[music]
Deuce Otsu version goudou